yes good afternoon
good afternoon uh ladies and gentlemen
and excellencies uh thank you so much
for making it
here today my name is christian
singleson i head up the eu's energy
regulatory agency called acer and i have
been tasked with three things
first to kick off
second to listen carefully over the next
60 minutes of discussion and thirdly to
conclude briefly but also punctually at
the end of the discussions
discussions which hopefully will revolve
around a possible transformation
of a dependency
on those we no longer deem dependable
towards an interdependence of sorts
amongst those whom we trust
and to kick us off we have the host of
today's meeting the danish prime
minister mr smithson and i pass the
floor to you mr prime minister
thank you and first of all thank you all
for coming to
mourinho
today to participate in the baltic sea
energy security summit
putin's brutal aggression is a
fundamental threat to europe's security
and we all know now that he is using our
dependence on russian energy as a weapon
to destroy our economy
and he will try to divide us
today
here at mourinho we are together to show
that we will never allow this to happen
and that we share a common vision a
vision of europe
free from russian energy
and of course also a vision of climate
at climate neutral europe in 2050
i think the marine board declaration
underlines
our commitment to that vision
we have the resources
we have the technologies now we must put
it all together in a way that can
provide
clean
and of course affordable energy
and a high level of energy security
in the short run
we must put all necessary instruments to
use but we must not move one from one
dependence to another
we will always be at risk if we are
dependent on fossil fuels
and that is why we have to speed up
the green transition
offshore wind
green hydrogen and so on
i am convinced that if we work together
we can achieve
these goals
but we have to do it faster
cheaper
now
and
of course the question is how can we do
this exactly because we all share the
vision but how how will we actually be
able to do it
where are the challenges that we have to
solve where are the opportunities
i hope
that today summit will give us the
guidance
on how to turn our vision into reality
and my guess is that all europeans are
looking at us because of the high prices
and because of inflation they need
answers from us i of course look forward
to getting started
and i am very very happy to see all of
you in denmark today
the european commission mrs ursula
vandalian mrs president thank you so
much first of all mata thank you so much
for the invitation i think i speak in
the name of all it's a splendid place
splendid weather and a fascinating topic
you have invited us too so thank you
very much for that
and it's urgent
you just said it we see energy prices
breaking record after record
the consequences for households and
companies are not sustainable anymore
and what we see is
yes an energy crisis but it's mainly a
fossil fuel energy crisis
so we need a green solution against this
fossil fuel energy crisis
as you know on the european level
repower eu is part of our answer
we are accelerating the clean energy
transition with an interconnected system
and there are many three main pillars
first of all it requires that we are
saving energy mainly fossil fuel energy
at european level we have agreed that
all member states to do jointly save 15
of energy between august now and march
23.
the second pillar is we need to
diversify away from russian fossil fuels
to reliable like-minded sources mainly
also to fill our storages
and here's good news
we have reached now an average in the
european union of starch filling of 80
percent so we are basically have reached
already
the amount that we have agreed on for
this year but we know that we will
increase the storage filling
and the third pillar is the main pillar
that is the knowledge that our
dependency on russian fossil fuels will
only be over if we invest massively into
renewable energy and that's why we're
here today so we need clean we need
cheaper and we need home grown
power
we need it big
and we need it fast
and that's why we propose to further
increase our 2030 target for renewable
energy up to 45 now
it means a renewable energy capacity of
around
1250 gigawatt by 2030.
just to put it in a frame today we have
340 gigawatt of wind and solar in the
european union of 500 gigawatt if you
take biomass
into the calculation
so it is thanks to you today too that
the european u european union goals are
totally within reach
the declaration that you will sign today
here
commits to multi multiply by seven
the current offshore wind capacity in
the baltic sea region that's amazing
to up to 20 gigawatt by 2030
this is already one third of the overall
eu ambition for offshore wind by 2030
one third
so it is evident
by working together
we can achieve more and quicker that's
the task of the day the benefits of
regional cooperation are immense
when offshore wind turbines are
connected to multiple countries the
costs are reduced
the impact on the environment is
minimized and the energy production
never goes to waste because it can flow
towards different markets at different
times
this is where solidarity
meets sustainability
and security of supply
now
we at the european commission will be
supporting your work in every possible
way from planning to permitting to
financing
we're back with full support the
regional cooperation initiatives like
this
since 2008 we have worked closely
together through the baltic energy
market interconnection plan you all know
it as bmip
the bmap high level group
this exemplary cooperation is on track
to fully integrate the electricity
systems of the baltic states with the
rest of the european union by 2025
already
i know we have to accelerate that's the
goal also to be faster there
so we need a lot of smart brains and of
course of financing to accelerate that
goal
this baltic
electricity system
integration has received continuous
support from the european budget with
more than 1.2 billion euros in financing
and here in copenhagen today we are just
building on that momentum
i want to highlight at the very end
three specific points where we can
accelerate the investment in offshore
wind first
let's agree to make hybrid projects a
priority when planning interconnectors
and offshore generation
hybrid projects which connect fin wind
farms to more than one member state
save up to 10 percent of the total
project costs
the commission is ready to work with you
to identify the incentives and of course
to overcome the possible bottlenecks
they're always bottlenecks so let us
know so that we work on that
a great example
of cross-border cooperation is the
elwind
offshore wind project between estonia
and latvia
and have good news
today the commission selected elwind
as a
so-called important cross-border
projects or pci and you know this is
good news because this makes it eligible
for eu funding
secondly let's make rapid progress with
grid network deploy development plans
based on common offshore commitments
the commission with nsoe will prepare by
september technical guidance to support
you in this work
and finally let's provide the political
backing to accelerate the permitting we
all know that this is one of the biggest
bottlenecks
we have put forward a proposal on the
table with three power eu
you the member states define the go two
areas and if you have done that then the
deployment of renewables and their
connection to the grid is an
overriding public interest that's
important because then we can fast
forward the permitting in within one
year
so this should qualify for the most
favorable procedures available in your
country let's make it real let's do it
fast
thank you very much mr president we'll
just proceed to the third and
final speaker the prime minister of
poland mr matthews thank you
your floor is yours thank you thank you
mata for organizing this this meeting
let me say a couple of words also about
energy but not only in the context of
energy transformation but maybe even
more focusing on energy security
because we do witness right now
geopolitical shifts
and we don't
know yet um what shape they will
eventually take
therefore we must rely on reliable
partners and so far we were discussing
at length
uh all sorts of different aspects of
energy transformation and we should
do so
in
in in the future as well
but supplementing
those discussions
uh we have to discuss also energy
security because
security overall it's not only about
strong army strong alliance but also
security of um
of
finances of our citizens and also
energy security
which we now so um painfully uh witness
uh as a missing link in our overall
economic and social architecture
russia has
wrapped a web of energy dependency
around europe like a spider
and many countries now have a very hard
time getting out of this
deadly
web
this
the invasion of ukraine is not the only
russian
military operation
the kremlin has been waging a gas and
energy war with europe for years
and this is why all our considerations
around energy uh should be
bearing in mind should bear in mind that
russia is using
energy as a weapon
and this therefore energy security
uh even more important than energy
transformation because there is no
energy transformation without energy
security
for too long the low price of russian
gas or cheap russian gas i should put it
in inverted commas
has been the most important value for
many countries
and the real price for cheap gas today
is the blood
of ukraine
we have learned how risky it is to rely
on unreliable partners as far as energy
issues are concerned
the plans to
block the baltic sea by russian gas
pipelines were a strategic mistake we
know this now
better late than never
we must replace both north stream
pipelines with green energy based
on sources belonging to democratic
countries and not to tyranny
the baltic sea should be the domain of
cooperation between european countries
as is the case at this summit
the domain of
also of offshore investment and i'm i'm
very happy that this discussion is start
starting right now maybe this there will
be a series of those summits
accelerating the processing
in not so distant future
after the black sea became a clear
target for
the kremlin
we should also be fearful of
potential further targets of
moscow which could be the baltic sea
and this is why i'm so um happy uh to
welcome finland and sweden as part of
nato because it clearly
makes
potential threats from russia
more difficult because the baltic sea is
almost becoming
an internal nato sea
offshore wind energy
constitutes one of the key directions of
transformation also of our
energy sector the energy potential of
the polish part of the baltic sea is
considered one of the largest in the
region by 2030
we're gonna have 13 of our electricity
generated from offshore and by 2040
around 20
um of our electricity
so
accelerating um the pace of
diversification is critical for us
but now
finally a couple of words on the climate
policy and the in the context of current
situation as well
we are united by our concern for the
climate
polish gas and offshore investment as
well as plans to build a nuclear block
uh enable us to strive for a low
emission economy in not so distant
future
poland has long talked about the need
for a reform of the ets and let me focus
on those two aspects um
at the at the at the end of my uh
intervention
we are now as ursula was saying
breaking one record record after another
more than 300 euro megawatts per hour
in
gas
or electricity in one year
electricity price for 1000 euro
this is not sustainable this is clearly
a
victory of
putin and his policy
therefore we should also use all the
uh armory in our arsenal to uh
counteract
uh those uh targets which uh which put
in
or the these instruments which put in
put in place
and i will mention two of them one is
ets system which should be suspended in
its current form for
one or two years or we could fix a price
or either a complete fixed price or
within
a bandwidth
um
for
one or two years as i said
just to
lower
the
the price for uh electricity for our
citizens and for our businesses as well
and second mechanism
which we should use
is
look at the long story short a pricing
mechanism which is being used by
uh
by the european commission
in the context of merit order and uh and
the pricing mechanism which event which
at the end of the day um is uh
creating huge tensions on the
electricity market and energy market
i
i think there will be opportunity to go
more deeply in our working sessions into
those but but i think it's badly needed
that we that we change it
and
finally it's worth quoting a climate
data that is rarely mentioned
apart from all the tragedy of war and
all that
atrocities and the barbaric russian
aggression there is uh one other
dimension
the greenhouse gas emissions caused by
russian invasion
are already greater than the plant
emission reduction in the eu for the
next three years by 2025.
so people who care about ecology that is
all of us uh should therefore be the
greatest greatest proponents of ending
the war
but please bear in mind that the the
quickest way to end the war is is to
lose it and we cannot afford to that
ukraine loses this war because this
could only encourage this would only
encourage putin to go after other
countries
so without the removal of russian
soldiers from ukraine the green
transformation in europe
will not be possible thank you
thank you very much uh mr prime minister
maybe a brief round of applause for
prime minister miss prime minister mr
president